Okay. Guten Abend. Ich bin Dr. Jawasch. Ich bin auf dieser Station Assistent-Assistentin.
Ich würde gerne das Aufnahmegeschrieb führen. Okay. Bitte zeigen Sie mir Bescheid.
Und wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, fragen Sie mir an. Okay? Gerne.
Okay. Erste, ich möchte Algaman fragen stellen. Wie heißen Sie?
Thomas Müller. Herr Müller, wie alt sind Sie? 60 Jahre alt.
Na, schuldigung, wer bitte? 60 Jahre alt. Wie groß sind Sie?
71. Wie viel wiegen Sie? 90 kg. 90 kg? Genau.
Okay. Herr Müller, was können Sie tun? Was ist das für Sie?
Ich habe in der letzten Zeit ein unangenehmes Gefühl im Bauch.
Das stört mich, Gefühl genau im Bauchbereich.
Und ich kann es nicht genau beschreiben, wie das ist, aber ich habe so ein manchmal Durchfall, manchmal Verstopfung,
manchmal Beleugung und so ganz komisch. Manchmal Bussball, manchmal Bullaunken, manchmal Verstopfung.
Unangenehm gefühlt im Bauch. Aber hat das sich gemerkt?
Ja, genau. Und vor allem, wenn ich Beleugungen habe, dann ist es so, dass mein Bauch ist wie ein Stein hart und ganz hart.
Und dann habe ich den spannenden Bauch, also das verinnernde Platz sofort.
Und in dem Zeitpunkt natürlich habe ich Schmerzen. Aber wenn ich zur Toilette gehe, dann geht es wieder besser.
Ich fühle mich, wie es mit dem Stuhl geht.
Ein gesamter Bauch. Und mit dem Stuhl, oder?
Nein, wenn ich auf die Toilette gehe, dann wenn ich mich entlassen könnte, zum Beispiel den Stuhl habe,
oder wenn ich durch die Belegung die Luft entleere, dann geht es mir wieder besser.
Das heißt, durch die Belegung und durch die Luft, was ich drin habe, dann parallel habe ich die Probleme.
Ich muss einfach dieser Luft entleeren.
Okay. Wie stark sind die Schmerzen? Vor einer ist bis zu 10, 10 leichte Schmerzen, und sie sind stark geschmessen.
Ja, genau. Wenn ich den Schmerzattacken habe, am meisten sind es bis zu 8, 9.
Ansonsten darf ich Schmerzen sowieso nicht. Das ist nur einfach, wenn ich Probleme habe, wenn ich mehr starke Bedeutung habe.
Zum Durchfall habe ich keine Schmerzen, auch bei Verstoffung habe ich fast keine Schmerzen.
Das ist nur selten, ja.
Aber ich komme nicht wegen Schmerzen her, als ich gesagt habe.
Vor der Grund liegt es bei mir, dass der Unangenehm ist, dass es ein unterschiedliches Gefühl im Bauch ist.
Okay. Wo genau ist der Unangenehm und gefühlt im Bauch? Wo genau?
Ober oder unter oder unter, oder links oder links?
Manchmal fängt es von links strahlend nach rechts aus, manchmal von rechts nach links, manchmal in der Mitte.
Das ist auch unterschiedlich.
Wander der Schmerzen?
Ja, genau. So wandert in aller Bereich.
Wander der unangenehm gefühlt?
Ja, Wander der Bauchschmerzen mit unangenehmem Gefühl.
Aber der unangenehm gefühlt ist nicht nur wegen Schmerzen, sondern auch wegen Verstoffung.
Nach drei, vier Tagen kann ich nicht gehen, dann habe ich Probleme.
Ich habe so einen voller Gefühl im Bauch, auch im Mahlenden, sozusagen.
Aber so stark Schmerzen habe ich nicht in dem Setpunkt oder in dieser Zeitraum.
Ein Durchfall ist auch unangenehm.
Ich kann nicht entscheiden, was ich zu mich einnehmen.
Soll ich etwas gegen Verstoffung oder Durchfall einnehmen?
Das ist ein echtes, komisches Gefühl.
Kann ich dir beschreiben, wann genau Durchfall angefangen hat?
Ich kann nicht genau sagen, wann angefangen habe.
Ich kann nicht genau nennen, aber ich kann sagen, dass dieser Wechselhaftstuhlgang seit ungefähr zwei Monaten.
Ich kann nicht genau nachvollziehen, wie es war, aber ich habe so ein unterschiedliches Stuhlgang in der Zeitraum.
Hatten Sie schon einmal einiges beschwerden?
Ja, in diesem Maß habe ich nie gehabt.
Vielleicht habe ich schon eine Verstoffung gehabt.
Durchfall nicht eine Verstoffung schon.
Wenn ich jetzt genau überlege, würde ich sagen, dass seit ungefähr mehr als ein Jahr habe ich Verstoffen.
Durchfall kam nie im Frage.
Seit zwei Monaten habe ich den Wechselhaftstuhlgang einmal verstoffen, einmal durchfall.
Sind diese Gefühle im Bau ungenehmen gefühlt?
Dort auf oder manchmal wieder weg?
Sie haben eine gute Frage gestellt.
Dauerhaft ist das nicht.
Ab und zu habe ich so eine Tage, wo ich sage, das ist alles vorbei.
Das war schon vielleicht, dass ich etwas gegessen habe, aber das ich nicht gut vertragen hatte.
Dadurch war die ganze Sache, dann kommt wieder.
Dauerhaft ist das nicht.
Gibt es etwas, das Verstarrt nach dem Essen oder das Verstärkte?
Ja, gute Frage.
Das habe ich nicht genau geachtet.
Ich habe Verstoffen, aber ich habe keine Lust, etwas zu essen, weil ich volle Gefühle habe.
Wenn ich Durchfall habe, dann muss ich viel trinken.
Natürlich habe ich das Durchgefühl, trinke ich viel.
Auch wenn ich durch den Durchfall bin, kann ich nicht nachvollziehen.
Aber so eine Auslöser kann ich nicht genau beschreiben.
Vielleicht Lageabhängigkeit?
Wenn ich viel laufe, dann ist es besser, weil dann kriege ich meine Stuhlgang.
Da muss ich viel laufen, auch dass ich auch diese Luft entlernen kann.
Aber Lagarung spielt keine Rolle.
Auch wenn ich nach rechts schlafe, nach links lege, setze oder hinlege, spielt keine Rolle.
Wie ist die Repetition?
Haben Sie abgenommen oder haben Sie abgenommen?
Ja, ich habe abgenommen.
Wie viele Kilogramm seid ihr?
Seit ungefähr 3-4 Monaten, fast 5 kg.
4 kg?
Abgenommen, okay.
Hab er eine Diät gemacht?
Nein, ich bin froh, wenn ich dann regelmäßig essen kann.
Ich habe am meisten keinen Appetit und es ist schwierig.
Sie haben gesagt, dass man manchmal Durst bemerkt.
Können Sie beschreiben, wenn man Durst bekommt, ein Durstgefühl?
Ja, während der Zeitraum, habe ich so ein Durstgefühl.
Da muss ich viel trinken.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Jetzt habe ich auch Durstgefühl.
Wie sieht es mit einem Stuhlgang aus, wenn Verstopfung oder Durstfalt gibt?
Ich meine, ich habe eine Farbeveränderung mit Stuhl gesehen oder bemerkt.
Das ist Ihre Frage, oder?
Ja.
Sie können auch so einfach fragen, wie sieht das Stuhl aus?
Sie haben eine Farbeveränderung gemerkt oder gesehen.
Das ist für Sie auch so einfache Frage zu stellen.
Ja, eine Farbeveränderung muss ich zugeben, dass ich gesehen habe,
ab und zu ist es ein bisschen dunkel.
Manchmal habe ich Blut drin.
Das ist in der letzten Zeit.
Ansonsten, so habe ich diese beiden Sachen gemerkt.
Manchmal habe ich auch Blut drin, manchmal ist es dunkel.
Das ist aber seit ungefähr zwei Monaten auch.
Seit dieser wechselnde Stuhlgang auch.
Das letzte Wahlplan hat Sie.
Ansonsten, ja.
Ich habe auch beide Dinge gemerkt.
Also diese beiden Sachen habe ich gemerkt.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie mit diesen Beschwerden schmerzen.
Ja, genau, ja.
Aber auch, wenn ich eine Belebung habe, habe ich den starken Schmerzen.
Okay.
Haben Sie erbrochen?
Aber ich habe erbrochen, aber nein.
Ich habe auch keine Überkeit gehabt.
Überkeit habe ich auch nicht.
Überkeit, ja.
Mir ist nicht schlecht.
Okay.
Wie ist das mit dem Wasserlassen?
Ist alles in Ordnung?
Ja, eigentlich muss ich sagen, ja.
Wasserlassen ist normal.
Jetzt, Herr Müller, willkommen,
Algamae-Fragen, Algamae-Justan-Fragen-Stelle.
Haben Sie höchstens Luftnot?
Husten habe ich keine Luftnot, würde ich nicht sagen.
Aber wenn ich mich belaste, dann habe ich natürlich nicht Luftnot,
sondern Druckgefühl auf dem Brust, ja.
Ja, und das ist auch in der letzten Zeit.
Aber es sind direkt Luftnot, die kann ich nicht genau jetzt reden.
Ja, alle habe ich nicht gehabt, nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich hatte auch keine Fieber, aktuell habe ich auch keine Fieber.
Mindestens dann habe ich nicht gespürt.
Schüttelfraus, Schweißausbrüche,
nach Schweißausbrüche, Katz, Schweißausbrüche, Katz, Schweißausbrüche.
Nach Schweißausbrüche, ja, in der letzten zwei, drei Wochen
schon etwas, aber nicht so dramatisch,
die ich als Beschwerden jetzt sozusagen beseitigen können.
Okay.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, in der letzten Zeit nicht so ganz.
Lechterzeit, gegen diese Beschwerde.
Gegen diese Beschwerde?
Ja.
Okay.
Wann waren Sie los damals im Urlaub?
Nein, in den letzten fünf Jahren nicht.
Ich war immerhin in Land zusammen.
Okay.
Ich will Ihnen nun gerne einige Fragen,
die Sie Ihrer Vorgesicht stellen.
oder wichtige Erkrankungen von denen ich wissen sollte.
Vielleicht Herzkrankheiten, Schilderuskrankheiten oder Blutdruckdicht anders?
Ich habe nur Blutdruckdruck natürlich, ich muss das auch so geben.
Ich nehme nur einfach seine Medikamente seit ungefähr fünf Jahren ein.
Das heißt Amludipin.
Wie viel Milligramm?
2,5 Milligramm.
Morgenstabend?
Ja, morgens.
Gibt es andere Erkrankungen, Krebs oder Döpfelschirmen oder Asthma?
Ich leide unter keiner anderen Erkrankung.
Der einzige war Blutdruckdruck und jetzt dieser Beschwingung, das ich aktuell habe,
weiß ich nicht genau, was ich noch habe.
Sind Sie operiert worden?
Ich bin nicht operiert worden.
Haben Sie schon einen Unfall gehabt?
Ich habe auch nie einen Unfall gehabt.
Haben Sie eine bestimmte Allergie gegen Plansen oder Medikamente
oder andere Nachrücks, Mittel, Flaschen, Laktos, Früchte, Kollektos, Intoleranz?
Okay, meinen Sie allgemein, wenn man die Frage stellt, haben Sie eine bekannte Allergie?
Ja, eine Allergie.
Können Sie auch so sagen, ja, habe ich keine oder unverträglichen, habe ich auch nicht.
Können Sie einfach so zusammen einfach auf die Frage stellen, das ist ein freies Fisch.
Müssen Sie nicht zählen wirklich, was gegen das?
Eine bekannte Allergie, ja, das ist auf eine.
Nehmen Sie Herr Müller andere Medikamente ein,
MyBederve oder die regelmäßige Medikamente?
Ja, in der letzten Zeit gegen Schmerzen schon.
Nehm ich so eine Nuvaldie, Trophen ein, so auch nur bei Bedarf.
Ne, genau.
Ist es helbfurch?
Helbfurch, ja, das ist helbfurch.
Okay, Herr Müller, jetzt wir kommen an Ihren Familiengeschichte.
Gib test, wichtige Erkrankungen mit Ihrem Familienanhörige,
Vater, Mutter, Geschwister, Kinder.
Ich habe keine Geschwister, meine Eltern sind nicht am Leben mehr,
die sind schon verstorben, ungefähr vor zehn Jahren.
Meine Mutter hatte Magentrebs, und meine Vater hat Lungenkrebs gehabt.
Und gestorben, leider.
Ja, leider.
Okay, und sind Sie verarbeitet?
Ne.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe gar nicht mehr.
Okay, Herr Müller, jetzt wir kommen an Ihren Gewohnheiten,
sagen Sie?
Ja.
Wie viele Sie werden?
20 pro Tag.
Seit wann nehmen Sie?
20 Jahre.
Wie bitte?
Okay.
Trinkers, Alkohol?
Ab und zu auch.
Wein oder Bier?
Bier.
Bitte nehmen wir,
wir haben einen kleinen
Privatprag, bitte.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Ne, habe ich nie genommen.
Okay.
Was ist Ihr Beruf, Herr Müller?
Ich bin Röntner jetzt, ich habe aus Gardner gearbeitet,
sondern Gartenfachmann.
Gardnerfachmann, okay, ja, Röntner.
Nehmen Sie alleine?
Ja, ich habe das.
Gibt es Stestation im Ihren Leben?
Was noch, bitte?
Haben Sie Stestation im Ihren Leben?
Stestation, habe ich gestresst bin im Leben.
Ja.
Gestresst bin ich, ja, jedes gestresst.
Sie sind auch gestresst, oder?
Ja, ich habe gestresst.
Ich habe gestresst.
Ja, jedes gestresst.
Sie sind auch gestresst, oder?
Können Sie mich sagen, was ist Ihr Stress?
Ja, Leben ist ein Versicht, selbst Stress, oder?
Leben zu leben, ist das Stress, ja?
Das ist Stress, ja?
Jeden Tag, morgen aufstehen und eingehen und
Haushalt machen, die sind alle stress, oder?
Ja, ja, aber...
Sie sind gestresst, so zu sagen.
Leben ist gut.
Ja, man freut sich trotzdem.
Wenn man keine Probleme beschweren hat,
wenn man gesund ist, ist das das Wichtigste, ja?
Aber jetzt bin ich nicht gesund,
ich gucke, dass ich jetzt genau habe.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Röntner, wir sind fertig,
aber gibt es andere Wichtigste Informationen,
was Sie möchten sagen oder hinzuwirken?
Ob ich noch hinzufügen soll, oder muss ich?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich habe alles erwähnt, was Sie erwähnen sollten, ja?
Ich glaube, wenn Sie noch Fragen haben,
bin ich bereit, das zu beantworten.
War nicht okay für mich.
Ich möchte jetzt, wir erst das Blut von Stabors abnehmen.
Was noch, weil?
Das heißt, Blutuntersuchung durchführen?
Ja, Blutuntersuchung und nachdem wir
eine körperliche Unterung haben,
das heißt, ich abhören Irabao,
ich abtasten Irabao und natürlich
Robgen Aufnahme und Ultraschall.
Ultraschall von Bauch?
Ja, Bauch und Ultraschall für Irabao.
Ich komme zu Ihnen in Ihrer Station.
Mir ist erwartet jetzt eine Blutuntersuchung.
Sie werden auch eine Ultraschall machen oder veranlassen.
Sie werden auch eine Röntgen veranlassen.
Sie können auch so sagen,
wir werden eine Röntgen veranlassen von der Bauch.
Wir werden den gesamten Befund zusammenbringen.
Mit Ihrer gedehnlichen Zustand werden wir dann
eine Entscheidung treffen, weil Sie genau haben.
Das wollen Sie jetzt genau sagen.
Okay, habe ich verstanden.
Okay, dann darf ich nicht hier.
Dann warte ich auf Ihre Entscheidung.
Okay, bitte warten Sie.
Die Pflegerin kommt jetzt gerade.
Nehmen Sie Platz.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Okay, Herr Prof.
Hallo Herr Kollege, ich bin ein Kollege zusammen.
Jetzt gehen wir los.
Okay, guten Tag.
Heute haben wir eine neue Patente in unserer Station aufgenommen.
Herr Neubler ist eine sechsjährige Patente,
die sich seit zwei Monaten bestehend
unangenehm gefühlt hat.
Unangenehm.
Unangenehm gefühlt.
Im Bau manchmal mit Schmerzen
und ab Deutschfall brauchen kann Verstopfung.
Manchmal Deutschfall, manchmal Diarrhea, manchmal Konstipation.
Obstipation, ja.
Obstipation.
Und er habe
ich denke,
das ist noch eine Beliebung.
Sie können es auch beklagen.
Ja, das ist eine Beliebung.
Wenn Sie, wenn er geht,
die Toilette, manchmal Deutschfall, manchmal Obstipation habe
und ihre unangenehm gefühlt hat,
dann ist das eine Beliebung.
Sie haben das gleiche Satz.
Sie haben schon erwähnt,
dass er stellt sich mit unangenehmes Bauchgefühl
und zu dem wechseln Stuhlgang,
mal Durchfall, mal Verstopfung.
Und nebenbei können Sie sagen,
der hat auch Belegungen.
Er freut sich, wenn er auf Toilette geht,
dass er sich entluft hat.
Dann der Satz beenden,
weil wenn Sie wieder Hunde greifen,
dann kommen Sie nicht weiter.
Okay.
Diese Beschwerde hat 2 Monate angefangen
und diese Erfüllung hat 2 Monate angefangen.
Und diese unangenehme Gefühle
im Bauch manchmal links und manchmal rechts,
ja wandelnde, unangefühlt.
Der hat seit 2 Monaten unangenehm gefühlt im Bauch
und die Schmerzen sind wandeln,
oder wirksalhaft, mal rechts, mal links, mal in der Mitte.
Ja, alle ganz abhause.
Ja, manchmal mehr abhause.
Seit einig Jahre haben Verstopfung,
aber letzte 2 Monate wechseln,
abhause manchmal Verstopfung,
und die Spassion manchmal die Jahre.
Und es gibt keine Auslöser.
Und der Patient berichtete,
letzte 3 oder 4 Monate 5 kg abgenommen.
Ja, okay.
Aber Sie können auch sagen,
der Patient hat in den letzten 4-5 Monaten abgenommen.
Müssen Sie nicht sagen,
der Patient berichtete oder der Patient hat in den letzten 4-5 Monaten abgenommen.
Schluss.
Versuchen Sie, so einfach Satz und klare Satz zu bauen.
Kompliziert Satz, bring nix.
Okay.
Und Ihre Schutulfarbe ist manchmal dunkel,
manchmal blutdrin.
Er berichtete keine Emesis, Nosea, Fieber,
Atomnopf und
Er berichtete,
er verneint,
oder Sie können auch sagen,
Fieber, Übelkeit, erbrechen,
wurde verneint.
Wenn Sie die ganze Beschwerin als Eines Satz
zu bauen,
am Ende wurde verneint,
dann ist es erledigt.
Sie können sich konzentrieren, dann geht es schnell.
Ja.
Als Vorherkrankung nannte die Patient Artilla Hepatoni.
Er nahm am Nofidin 2,5 mg,
einmal morgens 1.
Und bei Bedarf, gegen Schmerzen,
er nahm am Nofidin 2,5 mg,
ein Nehmen, und es ist herfreist.
Er hatte keine Allergie und Unverträglichkeiten.
Und in der Familie,
er nahm am Nehmen,
und hat Magenkrebs,
um gestorben,
und hat Vater,
er war ein Magenkrebsen,
er berichtete,
dass Sie gehört haben,
das können Sie nicht bestätigen.
Mutter sei Madenkrebs und gestorben.
Und Vater sei Lungenkrebs und gestorben.
Keine Geschwester und Kinder haben er.
Er ist sehr, sehr, sehr alt.
Ein Schatz seit 20 Jahren.
Und selten Alkohol trinken.
Keine Trinke.
Schön, dass Sie das verblieben haben.
Es gibt viele Leute, die das so nicht können.
Das ist eine große Fehler.
Versuchen Sie, jedes Satz neu zu bauen
und mit jedem Satz in den Problemen zu beschreiben.
Er trinkt keine Alkohol.
Er raucht 20 Zigaret pro Tag oder eine Schachtel pro Tag.
Andersrum ist er eher kompliziert.
Er kann sich nicht mehr konzentrieren.
Wenn Sie einen Moment haben,
dann ist es richtig.
Für mich ist das nicht nur, wie es für Sie klingt.
Ich würde es anders hören, als Sie es bauen.
Er ist einfacher und nicht komplizierter.
Nicht als Kritik annehmen,
sondern auch als...
Wir sind nicht für Kritik.
Nein, es ist nicht kritik.
Er ist nicht ein Korrektor.
Verstehen Sie die Zeit?
Es wird nicht gelassen.
Er ist rennt,
vorher ist er ein gegründeter Fachmann vom Beruf.
Er lebt alleine.
Ich habe viel Stress.
Was haben Sie vor? Was denken Sie? Was hat und was würden Sie jetzt machen? Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose und was ist Ihre Defaultdiagnose und wie würden Sie umgehen?
Aufgrund der armenischen Tischenangaben gehe ich von einer Verdachtdiagnose auf, Morbuskrom aus.
Ist nicht falsch, ja. Kann man denken.
Als die Frasiatövniersan kommen, unschativ Qualitis und geströntet ein.
Als die Frasiatövniersan kommt, unschativ Qualitis in Betra. Das ist meine.
Ja, was kann man noch? Ist nicht falsch. Es ist richtig.
Ja, vielleicht.
Aber Kolonkarcinom, vielleicht ja.
Warum nicht Kolonkarcinom als Konzedamencinom?
Wenn ich höre Kolonkarcinom, das ist Verdachtdiagnose, das ist Kolonkarcinom, ich denke.
Genau. Und die Frasiatövniersan ist anders.
Genau. Die anderen, die diese genannt haben. Ja, das ist nicht falsch.
Einer hat ein paar Kredites geschrieben, hier wird das nie im Falle kommen.
Wenn überhaupt denn der letzte Verdachtdiagnose.
Das ist der Literaris, Lucas Ventigli, den Betracht,
würde ich das auch nicht, auch in diesem Fall, annehmen,
weil es wiederum, das ist jetzt mal eine nichtpersistinende Probleme
im Sinne von, die eine chronische Pankretitis beschreiben kann
oder eine chronische Pankretitis oder was haben sie noch geschrieben?
Das muss ich gucken, Lucas Ventigli.
Weil, weshalb, weil der Charakter einer Verstoffung, die seit 4 Monaten vorhanden ist,
zudem hat frisches Blut im Stuhl, das ist schon ein anderes,
ja, chronische Damensinnung würde ich eher im Kauf nehmen
als eine Schulististätos oder Pankretitis.
Das heißt, wir bleiben jetzt mit einem chronischen Damensproblem.
Wir gehen nicht nach oben, wir bleiben jetzt mal unten
und wenn wir untenbereich ausgeschlossen haben,
dann kann man aber den anderen Teil als neben Diagnose oder Differenzialität
genauso überlegen. Okay, was machen Sie dann als Untersuchung hier?
Was wollen Sie sagen, ja, zu rungsig, ich nehme jetzt mal den Damensproblem.
Was würden Sie jetzt machen?
Ich erste, Baulterschologie.
Abdominalultrischal.
Was würden Sie, warum machen Sie Abdominalultrischal in diesem Fall?
Vielleicht, wir gucken Koleidoc und Pankreas.
Nicht schlimm, ja, okay.
Es ist schwierig, wenn Sie Belegung haben, mit einem Luft,
Sie werden das nicht darstellen, Sie werden das nicht schaffen,
das zu stellen. Ich glaube, im Grupp haben wir auch Radioloren bestimmt, ja.
Im Deutschen, Internisten machen und Chirur machen ihre Ultraschall selbst.
Sie schicken nie so Radioloren.
Und meines Erfahrungs ist so, dass mit einer Belegung,
mit viel Luft im Bauch, man wird das Bauch speise drüßeln,
auch den Scholleduch ist schwierig darzustellen.
Nicht Scholleduch, Pankreas, da können man schon, ja.
Da sieht man, wenn das ist Staun, da sieht man das schon.
Aber Pankreas, man ist schon schwierig.
Okay, ja, was ist noch, warum machen Sie Ultraschall?
Aber hier geht zum Damen, ja.
Sie haben eine Verdachtdiagnose, warum dann gucke ich es auf den Pankreas erstmal, ja.
Natürlich können Sie gerne gucken, Sie machen von oben nach unten,
aber Ihre Hauptziel, was wird das jetzt hier sein?
Okay. Und, entschuldige mir, fragen Sie etwas mehr?
Warum machen Sie denn Ultraschall als erstes?
Ach, Sirius, vielleicht Pankreatitis oder Versurusten,
Kordodokus oder...
Ja, Sie bleiben noch oben.
Entschuldigung, Sie bleiben noch mit dem oben Teil.
Wir vermuten aber auf darm Krebs oder grünsche Darmproblem, ja.
Sie machen Ultraschall hier um eine freie Flüssigkeit am Bauch auszuschönlich sind ein.
So als würde ich dann gucken, wie die Darmschlinge aussieht,
sind sie erweitert, ist die Darmband verdickt.
Ja, das kann man mit Ultraschall genau sehen, ja.
Weil Sie würden jetzt eine grünsche Darmenzündung oder eine Darmtumor...
Nein.
Darstellen ist schwierig, aber soweit es geht,
das ist gar keine Ausschlussuntersuchung,
das ist nur eine Voruntersuchung, was Sie vorhanden haben.
Wenn Sie nicht mit der Multarschall eine Kutpankreatitis
oder auch eine Darmprofration sofort oder Darmkrebs ausschließen oder diagnostieren,
aber das halt ist die Freiflüschung, freie Luft,
mindestens im Bauch, mindestens teilweise können Sie sehen,
oder eher so eine Darmpferdigung, Lymphknotenvergroßerung.
Ja.
Das würden Sie erstmal, ein Gesamt, dass jeder Erkrankung diese Sache,
würden Sie darstellen.
Dann noch, dass Sie können den Bauchspelzdrüsen,
genau, wie Sie gesagt haben, darstellen,
Sie können Scholledurches darstellen, Sie können eine Gallenblase darstellen,
Sie können eine Nehen darstellen, ja,
den Haarenblase auch die Prostataumabstattung weiter.
Ja, vielleicht können wir das.
Aber muss man sich auf den Probleme konzentrieren,
ansonsten können nicht jetzt alles in der Lude aufnahme machen,
Sie wollen sich auf den Probleme konzentrieren, okay?
Okay.
Und nachdem wir abdominal MR, MR, ich denke.
Ja, bevor, bevor, so, Radionäkologen, Sie machen, Sie machen eine Blutuntersuchung
erstmal, das ist schon mal wichtig.
Eine Blutuntersuchung, okay?
Ja, der erste ist in der Nudaufnahme nicht vergessen,
erst mal Blutuntersuchung nach Freien, Körperuntersuchung,
Blutuntersuchung, und dann gehen Sie zum Ultraschall,
und dann gehen Sie zu anderen Massnahmen, die Sie nicht in der
Nudaufnahme machen können, ja?
Okay.
Weil Sie haben so ein paar Sachen, die Sie in der Nudaufnahme
schaffen sollen, und da gibt es Sachen, die Sie nicht mehr in
der Nudaufnahme schaffen können oder machen können,
dann müssen Sie sich das Ruin anders verlegen.
Aber bevor Sie das nicht gemacht haben,
dann können Sie nicht zum Radilorischicken,
weil die Radilonfragen haben Sie den Nierenwetter,
okay, Sie haben ein Passivieren MRT geschickt,
oder das CT, wir werden jetzt ein Kontrastmittel geben,
haben Sie den Kreativierenwetter, sagen Sie,
nee, dann haben Sie Probleme.
Das ist unter Körperuntersuchung,
wir palpitieren Bauch, wir abhauen mit Stetoscope Bauch,
Bauch, wir palpitieren Bauch,
wir perkistieren vielleicht Leber oder andere Organen,
in Baramills oder vielleicht.
Aber wiederum, wenn Sie den Körperuntersuch machen,
Sie fangen mit dem Bauch an, Sie gucken sich an den
problematischen Stellen, wo dann jetzt,
weil es sind Klagtöber Bauchschmerzen,
dann gucken Sie wieder den Bauch aus,
sieht es geschwollen, es sieht eine Rotung,
sehen Sie eine druckende Schmerz,
eine Stelle, Sie gucken natürlich auf die Organen,
das ist vergroßert oder nicht,
grob können Sie auch schnell beschreiben,
die Darmbereiche, wenn Sie abtassen,
hat eine Blinddarmprobleme auch noch dazu,
trotzdem muss man tassen, das ist nicht schlimm,
ob Sie eine Herde auch abtassen können,
zum Beispiel wenn man hat eine Herde,
auch die man geimpft hat, die man bei Pritonealkastronose,
kann man manchmal auch das abtassen,
man kann das vorgeschritten haben,
so diese Sache, richtig,
und dann machen Sie die Blutuntersuchung,
was achten Sie bei Blutuntersuchung?
Ich weiss nicht, aber ich denke,
Zymormarker vielleicht.
Ja, erst mal in diesem Fall, bei jeder Erkrankung.
Ja, Hemoglobin, in Kolomkarstino.
Sie gucken auf den Blutbild einfach,
sagen Sie, ich schaue mal,
wie stark Blutarmut vorliegt,
wie niedrig der HBS,
und damit will ich auch den Leuchtsüten
auch sehen, auch den Natrifülen auch sehen,
und Tromsüten auch sehen,
wegen den Blutungen Tromsunzahl ist auch wichtig,
weil der hat eine Blutung,
und dann müssen die den Tromsunzahl auch haben.
Sie haben es gesehen, der hat ein HB von 10 Tromsunzahlen,
und 10 Tromsunzahlen sind 150.000,
dann hat er keine Probleme durch die Blutung
durch Tromsunzulie, wie nie,
sondern auch, dann machen Sie weiter,
Sie würden sagen, ich würde das Leben weiter schauen,
dienen weiter und noch Grinnungs,
Sie brauchen noch Grinnungs-Passur.
Wissen Sie, was Grinnungs ist?
Eh, nirgine Grinnungs,
nirgine und APTT,
was man in Standard-Halt macht,
die brauchen unbedingt bei sowas,
wenn jemand bei Verdacht einer Blutung
in der Notaufnahme sich vorstellt,
da müssen sie den Blutbild und Grinnungs-Unbedingt haben
mit dem Leben weiter,
dann haben sie das auch gemacht, richtig.
Und dann, Tumomarker können Sie machen,
es ist nicht verkehrt, aber können Sie machen,
dann machen Sie nur, dann wenn man fragt,
was würden Sie machen,
es ist so eine Einzel,
die man bei Kolonkarstenung Verdacht macht,
ja, sehr, sehr, 99,
dann mehr brauchen Sie nicht.
Und dann springen Sie auf Ultraschall,
dann machen Sie Ultraschall,
und danach, wenn Sie das auch gemacht haben,
Kolonspiegelung und MR, Abdomenemus.
Ja, das ist nicht verkehrt,
Sie machen eine Darmspegelung,
können Sie sagen,
aber in Deutschland sagt man Darmspegelung.
Vielleicht heißt der Darmspegelung.
Ja, das ist nicht verkehrt.
Sie können auch einen Darm,
wenn Sie keine akutes Ereignis haben,
im Sinne von nicht verschlussverdacht, ja,
Juliusverdacht, dann brauchen Sie nicht unbedingt eine MRT,
sowieso ist es schwierig, wenn überhaupt,
dann brauchen Sie eine CT,
aber wenn Sie verschlussverdacht haben,
dann müssen Sie eine CT machen sofort, ja,
dann kann Ihr eine MRT, dann macht man nicht,
in diesem Fall, macht man CT sofort, ja.
Aber wenn das nicht vorliegt,
dann machen Sie genau eine Darmspegelung,
sagen Sie, ich nehme Sie auf und machen wir morgen
eine Darmspegelung, ja, das ist nicht verkehrt,
zu gucken, wo das ist, ob das überhaupt eine Darm,
Krebs ist oder doch, wie Sie gesagt haben,
Differenzialdiagnose,
eine chronische Darmen-Sinnung,
und so ein Defkulitis oder Kron, ja,
das könnte auch sein.
Dann in Darmschütteln, wie kann ich Biopsy machen, vielleicht.
Genau, das können Sie entsprechend,
wenn Sie auch machen, ja,
und wenn Sie dort, wenn, das haben Sie gemacht,
und Sie haben gesehen, dass in der Kolonassünden
dort eine Darmpferdigung zu sehen,
mit einer unruhiges Gewebe,
Sie haben dann Biopsiert,
Sie haben es in der Pathologie geschickt,
Sie sind im Zwischen?
Im Zwischen,
weil in Pathologie,
drei bis fünf Tage,
kommt nicht sofort.
Konsultabteilung mit dem Zwischen,
Gastroenterologie,
ja, genau, aber Sie sind,
Sie sind Internisten, Sie sind in der Not,
nicht in der, auf Station tätig,
und Sie machen dann im Zwischen in CT, ja,
immer CT, ja, Sie müssen das genau,
auch wenn das der Brut ist,
auch Krone, das machen Sie in CT, ja,
immer CT kriegt man nicht sofort
in Krankenhäuser, ist schwierig,
Verkehr zu machen,
es ist gut, aber bei Agut zur Ereignis
der CT ist das Bestes.
Und CT haben Sie gemacht,
und haben Sie gesehen, ein rechtes
Kolonassindens-Tumor,
denn Stadion,
wenn wir nicht jetzt reden,
und ich glaube,
das ist ja reich, das ist aus.
Und nur meine Vorschlag,
versuchen Sie sich
auf den Problemen zu konzentrieren,
genau wie Piscata,
wie Sie sind,
und Sie versuchen nicht, wo Sie
spingen, ansonsten kommen Sie
durcheinander, ja. Zum Beispiel
in Obst-Passion haben Sie erwähnt,
dann springen Sie, seit wann
ist diese Obst-Passion? Ja.
Und der Auslöser, und dann
Schmerzen, seit wann ist der Schmerzen
und der Auslöser?
Und auch den,
den, den, den, den,
das ist einfach.
Okay?
Okay.
Alles klar.
Ich glaube,
müssen wir nicht jetzt über den,
die nur so unbedingt reden,
aber wir haben es genug besprochen.
War es so, dass ich mich so
auch, wo kann ich denn gehen?